[Musique]
on l'attend
omar makram fait partie des immigrants
du monde musulman arrivée en suède par
centaines de milliers au cours de la
dernière décennie en 2016 sa demande
d'asile est rejetée par la suède pour
éviter d'être renvoyé en egypte il prend
alors une décision risque
qu'elle est la seule chose qu'un
musulman ne ferai jamais profaner le
coran j'avais un exemplaire du coran
gelé piétiner j'ai craché dessus et j'ai
brûlé les actions de makram qui l'a
rendu public sur youtube non mise en
danger à bien des bsb lyon
en egypte il pourrait être poursuivi
pour blasphème et offense à l'islam pour
cette action avec cette vidéo il espère
alors montré à l'office national suédois
des migrations qu'en tant qu'ancien
musulmans son pays d'origine n'est pas
sur sa demande d'asile est finalement
acceptée en 2017
il y a quelques mois la profanation du
livre saint de l'islam par un autre
homme a déclenché les pires émeutes que
la suède ait jamais connue et a suscité
un débat sur la liberté d'expression un
pilier de la constitution suédoise
al'approche des élections législatives
de septembre
oui les week ends nous avons le choix
entre deux voies en ce moment soit tenir
bon et dire qu'ici mais vers une
démocratie libérale ici nous avons la
liberté d'expression et nous allons la
protégée soit décidé de faire un
compromis établir essentiellement un
lieu pour les fondamentalistes religieux
les deux formes demain
voici rasmussen pas la dame leader du
parti danois strahm course et candidat
déclaré aux élections suédoises grâce à
sa double nationalité
si la vidéo d'omar akram peut diffuser
sur internet n'avait eu qu'un écho
limité rasmus paladin nuit organise une
véritable tournée en suède dans
plusieurs villes il met le feu à des
copies du coran objectif montrer que
l'immigration de masse a nui au pays il
défend également le principe d'une
liberté d'expression sans limite
je ne critique pas les musulmans ce que
je critique c'est l'islam car l'islam
est une idée est donc peut-être
critiquer c'est un droit fondamental de
la suède dès que vous commencez à
interdire certaines expressions et
certaines opinions
il n'y a plus de liberté d'expression
la présence de pâles ou dan a provoqué
d'importantes émeutes dans plusieurs
villes les pierres à pâques cette année
plus de 100 policiers ont été blessés
certains politiciens de stockholm ont
plaidé en faveur d'une modification des
lois afin de donner à la police le
pouvoir d'arrêter des manifestations
comme celle de palau dan conséquence la
suède ressemblement à la suède est plus
à l'egypte selon makram dont la vidéo
sur youtube lui a permis de devenir
podcasteurs et chroniqueur de presse
fait il pas pouvoir critiquer une
religion y compris l'islam est une
violation de ce qu est une démocratie
libérale car ça signifie qu'il
existerait de fait une loi sur le
blasphème dans ce pays
mais des membres de la communauté
musulmane s'inquiètent d'être ciblés par
l'extrême droite sous couvert de liberté
d'expression
nous devons nous les gens civilisés de
définir des lits
sinon il peut arriver ce qui est arrivé
aux juifs pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale
ça a commencé comme ça
[Musique]
comme le philosophe disait là où on
brûle des livres sont finit par brûler
des hommes au milieu de ce champ de
bataille se trouvent des policiers comme
khalid rajar musulman fervent il est
arrivé en suède du liban lorsqu'il était
enfant quand le coran a été brûlé par
rasmus malouda n'a pas qu il était en
service raja je n'ai toute la journée et
s'occupait des émeutiers toute la nuit
j'ai été déçu et triste que des gens
sortent au nom de la religion pour
utiliser la violence afin de résoudre ce
problème
je suis policier
je suis musulman je suis suédois
je suis palestinien
je suis arabe pour moi il y a plusieurs
facettes
ma mère a fui une guerre la suède m'a
donné la sécurité et une éducation
est-ce qu'on empêche pas ludan de faire
ça parce que ça a créé le chaos
peut-être que si ça ne tenait qu'à moi
j'y mettrai un terme mais c'est la
constitution que je protège pas lui les
gens pensent alors ce que nous sommes là
ils disent pourquoi est ce que vous le
protéger ce n'est pas ça que nous
faisons
raja et ses collègues ont été attaqués
dans le quartier de rosengaard à malmoe
où il a grandi c'est la seconde fois que
des émeutes sidero la cause d'autodafé
du coran après un premier passage de
race mousse pas ludan en 2020 a pas que
cette année les voitures des habitants
ont été brûlés lorsque kaïs farès nous
rencontrent les traces d'un incendie
sont encore visibles sur le sol le
journaliste syrien pense que les racines
du problèmes vont bien au-delà de la
simple colère de la communauté musulmane
2016 ce sont des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont arrivées de pays
déchirés par la guerre comme la syrie
tous en même temps ce n'est pas une
chose facile je suppose qu'il y ait un
problème avec les différences
culturelles cela a fonctionné auparavant
la suède a déjà accueilli des irakiens
les libanais et palestiniens je n'ai pas
tellement vite problème de voitures
brûlées
est ce que la suède a un problème oui
elle en a c'est le logement alors ce
sont des emplois pour ces gens la suède
a pris ses responsabilités et elle y
travaille je ne suis pas satisfait de
tout ce qu'ils font mais au moins il
faisait ses
les suédois doivent maintenant décider
s'ils veulent encadrer la liberté
d'expression dans un esprit de compromis
al'approche des élections